عمر حامد سوداني مقيم في مصر وهو الاخر
وعان من ازمه شح الارز في المتاجر المصريه
ولكنه يفضل البحث عن البديل بدلا من
التعرض للاستغلال في بعض المحلات
بسعر طبعا اعلى لكن ما قاعدين ننزل
غيره صحيح صحيح
بينما تحدث اخرون عن عدم جدول توريد بهذه
الاسعار
عربيات وسواقين وماندوبين فطبعا لازم
السعر يبقى عالي معهم الحكومه لما لهم
السعر هم حسوا بالخساره ان هم يعني هامشي
الربح بتاعهم ما يقل فامتنعوا عن البيع
وفي بعض المتاجر تم اخفاء الارز عمدا لرفع
اسعار ايه بينما رفض البعض بيع كميات
كبيره حتى لا يساهم في احداث ازمات وفضل
ان يبيع الارز للزبائنه المستديمين فقط
وهذا انسحب ايضا على المتاجر المملوكه
للدوله التي رات ان تتدرج في ارضاء الطلب
حتى لا يحدث تخزين بدون سبب فبدات في لعب
دور التاجر المرجح مواطن بياخذ اللي هو
عايزه بس في حدود المعقول يعني احنا
عارفين ان حضرتك بتخش تشتري من عندنا
في الاسبوع 5 كيلو ارز اما نيجي واخذ 20
25 كيلو يقول لك اسف انت لا تاخذ 5 كيلو
بتوعك عشان غيرك يلا عشان ما نسببش ازمه
في الاخر
وتوضح هذه اللقطات التي نشرتها وزاره
الداخليه المصريه هي مها بالقاء القبض على
من يقوم بحجب الارز طبقا لقرار مجلس
الوزراء الذي اعفى من العقوبه كل من يقوم
بالاعلان عن مخزوماته وابلاغها لاداره
التموين المحليه تامر نصره العربيه
القاهره